do you think this christmas is going to
be considered better than last christmas
the prime minister proudly kicking off
the festive period turning on the
christmas lights with skill children in
downing street last week laughing off
questions about a parties said to have
been held in this very street behind
this very door last year allegra
stratton who was to become the prime
minister's press secretary appearing on
tv now in new footage obtained by itv
news she's seen rehearsing for that role
being asked some difficult questions
about a downing street christmas party
that the inhabitants claimed didn't
happen but listen to the tone just seen
reports from twitter that there was a
downing street christmas party on friday
night do you recognize those reports
[Laughter]
would the promise to condone uh how are
you chris
what's the answer i don't know i wasn't
the party it was cheese and water
there's cheese from mine all right it
was a business meeting
joking this is recorded
this fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
um one more and then one more um ask
anybody have any questions today there
are plenty more questions asked about
the party she says she went home but
from what
and does say in the alleged party was
not socially distanced amount to a
confession each answer leads to a new
question last year at christmas the
public followed the rules and many of
them didn't see their loved ones over
christmas
some of them didn't see their loved ones
again
they had the right to expect the
government to follow the rules and we
now know the government broke the rules
they parted
and now they're laughing about it
they're treating the public with
contempt the prime minister needs to
step up
accept what happened and apologize
unfortunately we've got a prime minister
who is socially distanced from the truth
tory mps are furious this is like
something out of
in the thick of it
if you wrote it
people wouldn't believe it boris johnson
has always been his own man and done his
own thing in his own way i think he has
a certain amount of explaining to do
for the first time tonight the leader of
the snp in westminster has actually
called for boris johnson to go over this
boris johnson has to resign you know
everybody followed the covered rules
last year people were told by the
government by boris johnson what they
were expecting to do i'm hearing from
constituents tonight that are just
frankly ashamed of what has happened
here ashamed but angry too the anger of
those who lost loved ones to covet named
on this wall opposite parliament anger
that has resurfaced tonight
the fact that this party took place
is compounding the awfulness
i can't begin to tell you how
the
160 000 families
who have been bereaved by this virus
are feeling right now when we see the
contempt
with which our loved ones lives and our
lives
are treated by this government it's
despicable it's bad enough that this
alleged event involved three dozen
people from downing street different
departments inside number 10 some people
coming in especially from home in order
to attend i'm told it's bad enough that
it took place two days after london went
into the most severe form of
restrictions known as tier three
what's really worrying tories tonight
however is the spectacle of downing
street aides laughing about an event
that they now deny took place
mocking the very rules that caused such
heartache a year ago
boris johnson took away the nation's
liberties because of covid if it turns
out we weren't all in this together
there could be painful consequences